-Performing "Sinister"
and "Chronicles"
from his new album,
"From A Bird's Eye View,"
once again, Cordae!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah, okay,
my flow sinister ♪
♪ This ain't rap music,
this straight literature ♪
♪ Small-minded,
all your ideas miniature ♪
♪ They tend to hate on ya
when they can't get rid of ya ♪
♪ I ain't going nowhere,
20-year career, minimum ♪
♪ Call Hit-Boy for beats,
ask for 10 of 'em ♪
♪ I don't follow trends,
I swing the pendulum ♪
♪ If she real bad, you know
I'm gon' give her some ♪
♪ Let's reflect times ♪
♪ I try to collect minds ♪
♪ From complex rhymes ♪
♪ And by the way, shout-out,
Tech N9ne, unh ♪
♪ Go and shut,
just let me talk ♪
♪ I'm a time bomb
that's waiting to go off ♪
♪ Quite nuclear, amazing what
fame could do to ya ♪
♪ Too peculiar, although I'm
truly a Renaissance starter ♪
♪ My mind divine,
it takes me a lot farther ♪
♪ Growing up, dawg, I really had
beef with my father ♪
♪ Why bother
explaining my feelings? ♪
♪ Try harder, but either way,
they gon' paint you
the villain ♪
♪ Eight months with no phone,
dawg, we aiming for brilliance ♪
♪ Hi Level, maintain
in the building, okay,
we making a killin', unh ♪
-♪ Okay, my flow sinister ♪
♪ This ain't rap music,
this straight literature ♪
♪ Small-minded,
all your ideas miniature ♪
♪ They tend to hate on ya
when they can't get rid of ya ♪
♪ I ain't going nowhere,
20-year career, minimum ♪
♪ Call Hit-Boy for beats,
ask for 10 of 'em ♪
♪ I don't follow trends,
you know I swing the pendulum ♪
♪ If she real bad, you know
then I'm gon' give her some ♪
♪ I know you heard that
my flow's sinister ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, they say that
♪ Just ask about me,
dawg, my flow's sinister ♪
♪ My flow's sinister,
my, my flow's sinister, unh ♪
♪ You heard 'em, they say
that my flow's sinister ♪
♪ Never lied in my rhymes,
you can go ask Jennifer ♪
♪ That's my mom's name ♪
♪ I create, find change ♪
♪ My mind frame ensures that
forever I reign ♪
♪ Let's get it ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How y'all feelin' tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Listen. Unh. Huh.
♪ On this road, and I'm not sure
where my heart is headed ♪
♪ And if you left me now,
I'll fall, regret it ♪
♪ Could you once,
think twice that I'm indebted? ♪
♪ I can't waste no time,
no, my time is precious ♪
♪ Hey, hit up
for that diamond necklace ♪
♪ Tell me you don't need it,
girl, and I respect it ♪
♪ When the world too much,
it's kind of headed ♪
♪ 'Cause you was on my mind
and use my dawgs as leverage ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ I've been travelin'
around these crossroads ♪
♪ Compromised some stuff,
and that's a small toll ♪
♪ Crazy, when we first met,
we was lost souls ♪
♪ I know I gotta grow ♪
♪ If I messed up, I'm sorry ♪
♪ Here's 50 racks
for the stress ♪
♪ Not easy to impress ♪
♪ Always wonder what's next ♪
♪ I go as deep as I can ♪
♪ Oh, darlin' ♪
♪ You say love is no miracle ♪
♪ And lust ain't
the whole thing ♪
♪ But trust is
something you should know ♪
♪ But we've both been
through pain ♪
♪ Yeah, unh ♪
♪ On this road, and I'm not sure
where my heart is headed ♪
♪ And if you left me now,
I know I'll fall, regret it ♪
♪ Could you once,
think twice that I'm indebted? ♪
♪ I can't waste no time,
no, my time is precious, yeah ♪
♪ Say my name, say my name ♪
♪ If no one is around you ♪
♪ Oh, darlin', unh ♪
♪ Yeah, unh ♪
♪ On this road, and I'm not sure
where my heart is headed ♪
♪ And if you left me now,
I'll fall, regret it ♪
♪ Could you once,
think twice that I'm indebted? ♪
♪ I can't waste no time,
you know my time is precious ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]